this last move is an indication that
fabbi is and rook g1 and more he's not
offering the drama and I think Richard
can you go back it's dangerous
especially because you see that on Angie
- so now it's a threat but it's white
[Music]
and we have breaking news the game is
over
Fabiano Carolina has won against
Alexander in style Brad come November he
will challenge Magnus Carlsen for the
world title and there are cheers going
on in the job this is a match everybody
has wanted to see
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
since you know how does it feel to watch
your youngster pull this off and is now
the Challenger to the world title
doesn't like a dream ah
and maybe I wake up but I'm very excited
I'm very excited for Fabiano either
services I can't believe it my largest
is moving
[Applause]
I'm absolutely thrilled to him coming
into today I wasn't sure what would
happen and somehow things just came
together perfectly at the end so it's I
really couldn't be happier I mean it's
still so far away but I'll prepare very
seriously and it'll be a tough flight